hablemos de algunas de las diferencias
entre como ocurre la traducción en las
células procariotas y como ocurre en las
células eucariotas y quiero centrarme
principalmente en el rm justo antes de
que esté listo para ser traducido
comencemos con nuestro adn m procariotas
y veamos primero la sección 5 prima
tenemos esta parte amarilla aquí que es
la región no codificante se llama región
no codificante porque el ribosoma en
realidad no leerá esa parte entonces esa
secuencia particular de aminoácidos no
es tan importante después de la región
no codificante tenemos las secuencias
indagarlo y las secuencias ya indagar no
es el sitio que el ribosoma va a
reconocer y el que va a unirse así que
simplemente dibujemos un ribosoma por
aquí aquí es donde se unirá al ribosoma
procariotas y luego después de la
secuenciación del gar no tenemos otra
región no codificante que voy a abreviar
como rnc y luego tenemos nuestro codón
de inicio que generalmente es auge que
nos dice que comencemos a traducir y así
el ribosoma comenzará a traducir leer a
toda esta sección
la cadena de polipéptidos
correspondiente hasta llegar al codón de
paro que le dice que deje de traducir y
luego tenemos otra región no codificante
veamos nuestro nm eucariota es bastante
similar pero podemos ver que hay algunas
diferencias comenzaremos con el extremo
5 prima vemos este nucleótido rojo justo
aquí ese es la capa 5 prima y la capa 5
prima es simplemente un nucleótido de
guanina así que voy a dibujar una g
adentro guanina y tendrá un grupo metilo
en algún lugar de la molécula así que
voy a dibujar un grupo metilo y el
enlace entre esta guanina y el
nucleótido que se encuentra cerca de él
es un enlace diferente al que
normalmente se encuentra entre dos
nucleótidos y eso es realmente todo lo
que tiene la cap synco prima y la capa 5
prima es en realidad el sitio de unión
ribosomas en eucariotas eso significa
que en las eucariotas el ribosoma va a
reconocer esta parte en particular y se
unirá a ella después de la capa 5 prima
tenemos esta otra región no codificante
que el ribosoma no va a traducir y luego
el ribosoma llegará nuevamente al codo
de inicio auge que le dice que comience
por lo que traducir a toda esta sección
hasta llegar al codón de paro luego
tenemos otra región no codificante y
después nos topamos con algo que se ve
diferente de lo que hemos visto en el
aire nm procariotas esta sección con
nucleótidos azules que se llama la cola
poli
y la cola poli a es un grupo de
nucleótidos donde todos son a la de
minas por lo que dibujaré a dentro de
todos estos nucleótidos la cola poli am
en realidad es bastante larga
generalmente tiene entre 100 y 250
nucleótidos de largo eso es bastante
largo no lo dibujé exactamente escala y
el propósito tanto de la cab synco prima
como de la cola poli a es evitar que
éste arne m se ha degradado por enzimas
actúan como una especie de señal que no
permite que las enzimas lo dijeran o
degraden y quizás nos preguntamos qué
pasa con el arn procariotas como es que
no tiene nada similar para evitar que se
degrade y la respuesta breve a esa
pregunta es que en las moléculas
procariotas la transcripción y la
traducción ocurren
en el mismo lugar las células
procariotas no tienen exactamente un
núcleo tienen citó sol y la
transcripción y traducción ocurren en el
mismo lugar y no sólo suceden en el
mismo lugar sino que pueden suceder al
mismo tiempo por lo tanto podemos tener
un pedazo de rm que se está formando y
mientras se está formando un ribosoma se
unirá a él y lo traducirá pero en las
células eucariotas las cosas son un poco
diferentes la transcripción ocurre en el
núcleo y la traducción ocurre en el
citoplasma donde hay ribosomas y
entonces el arn una vez hecho tiene que
viajar desde el núcleo hasta el
citoplasma donde están los ribosomas y
debido a que viaje esta distancia
relativamente grande se encontrará con
muchas cosas diferentes incluidas las
enzimas que podrían degradar lo por lo
tanto necesita esta protección adicional
para evitar que se dañe de alguna manera
hay una diferencia más en la forma en
que ocurre la traducción en procariotas
y eucariotas de la que quiero hablar y
trata de cómo es el primer aminoácido en
la cadena de polipéptidos en las células
procariotas el primer aminoácido de la
cadena es
la forma y el metionina y la forma y
metionina es simplemente el aminoácido
metionina pero con un grupo formado
unido y en caso de que no recuerden cómo
se ve un grupo por milo se ve así en las
células eucariotas el primer aminoácido
en todas las cadenas de polipéptidos es
simplemente metionina y es interesante
notar que la forma y el metionina en
realidad actúa como un sistema de alarma
en el cuerpo humano si tuviéramos
algunas células bacterianas dañadas en
nuestro cuerpo habría forma y metionina
flotando y eso le dice a nuestro cuerpo
que hay bacterias alrededor y
desencadena una respuesta inmune